[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Montag Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport einen schönen guten
Abend
frische Nachricht das Ergebnis des
Stresstests für die Stromversorgung ist
da
Reserve für den Notfall zwei Süddeutsche
Atomkraftwerke sollen länger
einsatzbereit bleiben bis April 2023
neues Gesicht in der Downing Street List
Trust gewinnt den Vorsitz der britischen
Konservativen und folgt Boris Johnson
als Premier
bitte um Vergebung 50 Jahre nach dem
Olympia Attentat von München
entschuldigt sich der Bundespräsident
bei den Angehörigen der Opfer
[Musik]
eigentlich war der Ausstieg aus der
Atomkraft Ende des Jahres fest
beschlossen doch dann griff Russland die
Ukraine an und lieferte immer weniger
Gas und jetzt kündigt ausgerechnet der
grüne Wirtschaftsminister an dass zwei
Atomkraftwerke für Notfälle weiter
bereit bleiben sollen um die Versorgung
zu sichern weil ein aktueller Stresstest
das nahe legt bis April sollen die
Kraftwerke Isar 2 und Neckarwestheim für
den Fall eines stromengpasses noch zur
Verfügung stehen
in Deutschland fragen wir Theo call in
Berlin was bedeutet das jetzt
also mein Eindruck ist es die Ableitung
aus dem Ergebnis des Stresstest die
spiegeln fast exemplarisch sowohl den
pragmatischen als auch den politischen
Kernbereich der Grünen und ihres
Wirtschaftsministers wieder also alle
drei Atomkraftwerke werden wie geplant
vom Netz genommen das ist der Bereich
der auch der politischen
Grundüberzeugung der Grünen entspricht
und zugleich behält man zwei davon in
diesem Winter als eine Art stiller
Reserve für mögliche krisenhafte
Situationen im Stromnetz das ist dann
der pragmatische Teil des grünen
Wirtschaftsministers also diese
notfall-reserve soll nur für diesen
Winter nur bis Mitte April gelten danach
sei auf jeden Fall Schluss neue
Brennelemente würden nicht geladen denn
so hat Habeck noch mal betont Atomkraft
bleibe eine hochrisikotechnologie und
belaste künftige Generationen mit
radioaktiven Abfall diesen Weg der
abwartende notbereitschaft den hat die
Union sofort scharf kritisiert denn sagt
sie man zahle auch den Stillstand denn
auch Notbetrieb gäbe ist ja nur mit
Kostenerstattung und damit zielt die
Kritik im Grunde genau in die
Schnittstelle zwischen harbex
pragmatischer und parteipolitischer
Linie vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
Theo call war das live aus Berlin
eine Antwort der Bundesregierung auf die
steigenden Energiepreise ist auch das
dritte Entlastungspaket seit gestern ist
klar dass es Einmalzahlungen für Rentner
und Studierende geben wird dazu ein
höheres Kindergeld und mehr Menschen
sollen Wohngeld bekommen aber andere
Bestandteile dieses Pakets sind noch
ziemlich vage außerdem kommen von allen
Seiten weitere Forderungen Thomas
Reichert berichtet am Tag nach der
Einigung klingt der Erleichterung seufze
aus der Ampel noch immer nach eine 65
Milliarden Entlastung für die Bürger das
hilft nach einem Sommer voller Streit
natürlich auch der Koalition
das ist ein wichtiges Signal und das ist
bei drei unterschiedlichen
Koalitionspartnern und ihren
Vorstellungen auch sehr unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen darüber gibt was wir
priorisieren oder wo wir mal um Lösungen
Ringen ist doch völlig klar die Linke
findet das trotz der Hilfen eine Lawine
sozialer Verarmung drohe es handelt sich
um ein Paket was die Zukunft der Ampel
sichern soll aber was für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger was den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wirklich nur
unzureichend hilft Wohlfahrtsverbände
begrüßen die Unterstützung aber die
schwächsten hätten noch mehr und noch
schneller entlastet werden sollen das
Problem für uns als Wohlfahrtsverband
beschützen insbesondere darin dass für
Menschen in der Grundsicherung in diesem
Jahr nichts mehr passieren wird obwohl
diese Menschen jetzt schon nicht mehr
wissen wie sie das Ende des Monats
finanziell überhaupt erreichen sollen
auch die Wirtschaft hätte sich mehr
gewünscht nach einer Umfrage des BDI
fühlen sich über 90% der Befragten
Mittelständler durch die Energiepreise
stark oder existenziell beeinträchtigt
das sind Zahlen die einfach klar machen
wie kritisch die Lage in der Wirtschaft
ist und hier würden wir uns mehr
Engagement der Politik auch Wünschen aus
dem derzeit in Niederbayern kommt heute
dagegen Lob dafür dass nur noch Rentner
und Studierende eine
energiepreispauschale erhalten
das Scholz mit den Ländern reden sie
sollen schließlich mitteilen
wer profitiert wie vom dritten
Entlastungspaket Details dazu haben wir
in der ZDF heute App genau wie weitere
Reaktionen
in die Ukraine in der südukrainischen
Region soll vorerst doch kein Referendum
für den Anschluss an Russland
durchgeführt werden das teilten die Pro
russischen Behörden in der zuletzt
wieder stark umkämpften Regionen mit der
ukrainische Präsident selensky sprach in
seiner abendlichen Videobotschaft von
weiteren Gelände gewinnen im Süden und
Osten unabhängig überprüfen lässt sich
das derzeit nicht
sie alle waren Sport begeistert
Ringe Gewichtheber Fechter Trainer der
jüngste 18 der älteste 53 Jahre alt
Mitglieder des israelischen
Olympia-Teams und ein deutscher Polizist
sie alle starben beim Attentat auf die
Münchner Sommerspiele genau vor 50
Jahren für das Versagen der deutschen
Behörden hat der Bundespräsident auf der
Gedenkfeier heute um Vergebung gebeten
dazu gleich mehr zunächst ein Rückblick
von Alexandra Vacano
bunte heitere Spiele die Bundesrepublik
möchte sich von ihrer besten Seite
zeigen neun Tage Rekorde und Medaillen
dann das morgens kurz nach halb fünf
überfallen bewaffnete Palästinenser das
israelische Team erschießen zwei
Menschen und nehmen neuen Geiseln eilig
einberufen ein Krisenstab dabei
Innenminister Genscher es folgen Stunden
der Verhandlungen und Drohungen jede
Stunde eine Geisel zu erschießen auch im
Olympischen Dorf Schaulustige Reporter
Kamerateams die Welt schaut zu aber auch
die Terroristen wie Polizisten als
Sportler verkleidet das
apartment-stürmen wollen die Aktion
scheitert
kurz nach 22 Uhr in Hubschraubern werden
die Terroristen mit ihren Geiseln
Richtung Militärflughafen gebracht sie
wollen nach Kairo auf dem Flugplatz dann
Feuergefecht beim Versuch der Polizei
die Israelis zu befreien die neuen
Geiseln sterben wie auch ein Polizist
außerdem fünfte acht Terroristen
Terror Mord Trauer dennoch am nächsten
Tag verkündet der Präsident des IOC
die Spiele müssen weitergehen
die deutschen Behörden haben während und
nach dem Attentat beschämende Fehler
gemacht das wurde auch auf der
Gedenkfeier deutlich wir haben fünf
Jahrzehnte justizversagen durchgemacht
sagte die Witwe eines der Opfer erst am
Mittwoch hatte sich die Bundesregierung
mit den Hinterbliebenen auf
Entschädigung und weitere Aufarbeitung
geeinigt aus München berichtet Stefan
leifert
andre spitzer
zwölf Namen zwölf Schicksale 12
Erinnerungen an ein singuläres Versagen
deutscher Sicherheitsbehörden es ist
eine bittere Zeitreise die die
Hinterbliebenen des olympia-attentats
mit ihrem München Besuch Unternehmen am
Fliegerhorst Fürstenfeldbruck wo die
Geiselnahme tragisch endete hören sie
vom Bundespräsidenten die Worte auf die
sie so lange gewartet haben ich bitte
Sie als Staatsoberhaupt dieses Landes
und dem Namen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
um Vergebung um Vergebung für den
mangelnden Schutz der israelischen
Athleten damals bei den Olympischen
Spielen in München und für die mangelnde
Aufklärung danach dafür
das geschehen konnte
das geschehen ist
schonungslos listet Steinmeier das
vielfache Versagen der deutschen
Behörden und Regierungen auf Worte wie
Balsam auf die Wunden die Deutschlands
Umgang mit dem Attentat in Israel
hinterließen
es ist eine globale Tragödie an die bei
allen Olympischen Spielen erinnert
werden muss deren Lehren jeder
Generation gelehrt werden sollten
Anki spitzer verlor in München ihren
Mann André Israels fecht-trainer in
einem bewegenden Brief an ihn lässt sie
den Schmerz erahnen der auch in 50
Jahren nie nachließ wenn die Mörder ju
als sie dich ermordeten haben Sie auch
einen Teil von mir umgebracht und von
allen die dich liebten haben sie die
Hoffnungen unsere Träume unsere Zukunft
ausgelöscht aber nicht meine Liebe für
dich
nichts wünschen sich die Angehörigen
mehr als das die Wunden endlich heilen
können dieser Tag könnte ein Beitrag
dazu gewesen sein
[Musik]
premier Boris Johnson das war einmal
nach Skandalen Lügen und partygate
wissen die Briten seit heute wer sie an
seiner Stelle durch zunehmend schwierige
Zeiten führen wird Liz Trust heißt die
neue bislang Außenministerin gewann sie
die Stichwahl innerhalb der
konservativen Partei gegen den früheren
Schatzkanzler regissonak es wartet ein
Haufen Arbeit immer mehr Briten sind von
Armut bedroht die Inflation nähert sich
13 Prozent allein die Energiepreise
haben sich verdreifacht Verena Garrett
alles andere wäre eine Überraschung
gewesen
172.000 Parteimitglieder der
konservativen waren aufgerufen
abzustimmen mit 57% ist sie die neue
Parteivorsitzende und wird
Großbritanniens neue Premierministerin
Listros
ich werde liefern einen großen Plan zu
Steuersenkungen und Wirtschaftswachstum
ich werde liefern in Sachen Energiekrise
und ich werde mich mit den hohen
Rechnungen der Menschen befassen das
wird sie müssen schnell bislang hat sie
es vermieden konkret zu werden Liz Trust
stammt aus einem eher linken Elternhaus
war eins liberaldemokratin mit 19 sprach
sie sich klar dafür aus über die
Abschaffung der Monarchie abzustimmen
gerade da ein paar Jahre später
wechselte sie zu den konservativen es
bleibt nicht die erste 180 Grad Wende
ihrer politischen Karriere 2016 noch war
sie für den Verbleib in der EU
mittlerweile ist sie brexit Hardlinerin
das Verhältnis zwischen Großbritannien
und Europa wird angespannt bleiben
schießween very trasiva sehr hart bei
der Umsetzung des brexits und hat
klargemacht dass es kein Zurück gibt
Bahn Nordirland Protokoll wird es schwer
werden mit ihr umzugehen sie wird nicht
einfach nachgeben und sich dem
Anschließen was die EU vorschlägt
morgen wird sie offiziell von der Queen
als Premierministerin ernannt dann will
sie sich mit einer Rede an die Nation
wenden die erwartet konkrete Lösungen
von der neuen in der Downing Street
Frankreich musste in den vergangenen
Jahren viele islamistische Anschläge
verkraften einer der schlimmsten war
2016 in Nizza am 14 Juli dem
französischen Nationalfeiertag raste ein
Attentäter mit einem LKW über die
belebte Strandpromenade 86 Menschen
starben auch drei Deutsche der Terrorist
wurde von der Polizei erschossen
mutmaßliche Helfer sitzen seit heute vor
Gericht aus Paris berichtet Anna
Warsberg
es schmerzt immer wieder aufs neue wenn
an müris hierherkommt und an ihre
Tochter denkt kamie war 27 als sie beim
Attentat getötet wurde und bei mir so
kam ein lange Zeit konnte ich in meinem
Haus nur im Esszimmer sein ich konnte
nicht mehr in den Garten gehen weil die
letzten Momente mit Kamin im Garten
waren ich konnte nicht in den ersten
Stock gehen wo mein Zimmer ist weil mein
Zimmer neben ihrem war auf die Promenade
von Nizza will und kann an nicht gehen
sicherheitspoller erinnern an den 14
juli 2016 als ein Mann mit Tonnen
schwerem LKW hier Zickzack durch die
Menge Rast und innerhalb von vier
Minuten 86 Menschen in den Tod reist
Hunderte verletzt jetzt beginnt der
Prozess um die islamistisch motivierte
Tat und über 850 Nebenkläger wollen
Antworten
die Frage die alle Opfer umtreibt ist
wäre es möglich gewesen ein solch
schreckliches Verbrechen zu verhindern
ein Teil kriem urriebel acht Personen
sind angeklagt sie sollen dem Täter
geholfen haben die Todesfahrt
vorzubereiten er selbst wurde von
Polizisten noch am Tatort erschossen und
im Urlaubsort Nizza ist das Attentat
Teil vom Alltag geworden
mitten in einer Tragödie genau dort wo
wir vorher entspannt spazieren gegangen
sind
ich gehe nicht mehr zu Feuerwerken ich
gehe nicht mehr auf die Terrassen
zu sprechen sie ist froh dass der
Prozess nach sechs Jahren nun endlich
beginnt
Entsetzen heute in Kanada eine Serie
blutiger Messerangriffe erschüttert das
Land mindestens zehn Menschen wurden
getötet 15 weitere verletzt einige von
ihnen schwer die Polizei berichtet von
zwei Tätern die auf Menschen einen
starken in der entlegenen Ortschaft
James Smith Screen Nation und einem
kleinen Nachbardorf Johannes Hanau
berichtet es ist ein Blutbad verübt mit
Messern an einem Ort der so weit weg
scheint von den Verwerfungen unserer
Zeit das kleine Dorf Welden in der
zentralkanadischen Prärien des sketchuan
sitzt der James Smith tree first Nation
aus heiterem Himmel ohne Vorwarnung
bricht in dem ländlichen Idyll das Böse
über die Menschen herein
in diesem Zeitpunkt unsere Untersuchung
haben wir in der Gemeinde Welden der
James mit first Nation 10 getötete Opfer
an 13 Tatorten gefunden
weitere Opfer wurden verwundet 15 wurden
in verschiedene Krankenhäuser gebracht
verdächtig sind Damien und Miles
Anderson seit gestern läuft rund um die
Uhr die Fahndung in einem Gebiet etwa
fünfmal so groß wie Deutschland bislang
ohne Erfolg der polizeischiff der
Provinzhauptstadt Regina vermutet dass
die beiden Tatverdächtigen bei
Verwandten Freunden oder Bekannten
untergetaucht sind
wir sind uns sicher dass jemand da
draußen weiß wo die gesuchten sich
aufhalten und wertvolle Informationen
für die Polizei hat und ich bitte Sie
eindringlich Kontakt mit der Polizei
aufzunehmen noch aber sind die
Verdächtigen weiter auf der Flucht und
noch ist über das Motiv für das Blutbad
nichts bekannt fest steht nur es ist
eines der brutalsten Massakern der
jüngeren kanadischen Geschichte mitten
in der Prärie
in Bremen ist eine Transfrau in der
Straßenbahn angegriffen und schwer
verletzt worden nach knapp 15
Jugendliche beleidigten laut Polizei die
Frau einer schlug ihr dann mehrfach mit
beiden Fäusten ins Gesicht als Fahrgäste
einen Schritten flohen die Angreifer vor
gut einer Woche war in Münster ein
25-jähriger Transmann niedergeschlagen
worden er starb später im Krankenhaus
seit vorgestern brennt es am Brocken im
Harz und noch immer ist das Feuer nicht
unter Kontrolle weil das Gebiet
unterhalb des Gipfels schwer zugänglich
ist sind vor allem Löschhubschrauber im
Einsatz dazu auch zwei Löschflugzeuge
aus Italien trotzdem brannten rund 150
Hektar ab die Ursache ist noch unklar
und jetzt Tennis Norbert bei den US Open
ist der Titelverteidiger in einem
spektakulären Achtelfinale ausgeschieden
in eins zu drei Sätzen gegen Australiens
Tennisstar nickiaries von dem man ja
sagt mal sehr genial mal etwas gaga aber
immer unterhaltsam so auch bei einer der
kuriosesten Szenen der Turniergeschichte
vieles lief perfekt am Spiel von kirgios
im Hintergrund so perfekt dass er
übermütig wurde ein Schlag auf der
anderen Seite des Netzes nicht erlaubt
der Punkt wäre seiner gewesen nun wurde
der Medvedev zugeschrieben doch das
spielte schließlich keine Rolle mehr den
druckvollen Spiel des Australiers konnte
der Russe immer weniger entgegensetzen
mit WTF sichtlich genervt ein trockenes
Ast zum viersatzerfolg
kirgios im Viertelfinale der
Weltranglisten erste packt seine Sachen
und Tennisbälle mit der Signatur des
Siegers stehen nun immer höher im Kurs
morgen startet der Gruppenphase der
Champions League erstmals mit fünf
deutschen Vereinen RB Leipzig in der
Bundesliga bislang enttäuschend trifft
auf den 13-maligen ukrainischen Meister
Donezk zwischen Leipziger Anspruch und
Wirklichkeit klaffen Lücken gerade nach
dem Spiel in Frankfurt
Leistung angeht das war ab dem Moment
einfach zu wenig der Pokalsieger geht
gegen Frankfurt 0:4 unter das Wort Krise
fällt aber nicht zweites ein Spiel dabei
wo die grundtonen gefehlt haben dann
jetzt Kathrin Krieg im Kopf den Fußball
aber im Herzen super Flügelspieler super
1:1 Spieler
und ja sind in der Lage
weh zu tun das erste Saisonspiel der
Königsklasse für beide Teams eine Frage
der Mentalität
gestern Abend Fußball-Bundesliga das
zweite Sonntagsspiel und da hat Mainz
überraschend in Gladbach gesiegt den
Treffer des Tages für die Gäste erzielte
Aaron Martin in der 55 Minute erste
Niederlage der Borussen in dieser Saison
Mainz rauf auf Tabellenplatz 5 Gladbach
unter auf den 9 Platz
und alle Toren Zusammenfassung der
Begegnung des fünften Spieltags auf ZDF
heute.de und in der ZDF heute App
Dankeschön bitte Norbert die Woche
bringt Regen erst vereinzelt in der
zweiten wochehälfte gibt es dann mehr
die Details hat gleich Katja horneffer
im heute-journal um halb elf spricht
Marietta Slomka mit Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck danke für Ihr Interesse einen
schönen Abend ihnen noch und bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend die Nebelfelder hier in
Tschechien und Österreich lösten sich
heute über Tag alle auf dann
entwickelten sich einige Quellwolken und
dieses Tief Peggy schaufelt von
Südwesteuropa nochmal schwülfeuchte Luft
in den Südwesten Deutschlands so gab es
schon die ersten Schauer und Gewitter
und mit denen beschäftigen wir uns auch
noch in der Nacht auch im Osten kann es
einzelne kleine shower geben meist
bleibt die Nacht allerdings trocken bei
Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 18 Grad am
Niederrhein und 10 Grad in der Uckermark
dieses west-ostgefälle bei den
Temperaturen bleibt uns auch morgen über
Tag erhalten am Rhein steigen die Werte
noch mal auf 29 bis 30 Grad im Nordosten
ist es dagegen deutlich kühler mit 20
bis 22 Grad morgen Vormittag kann das
erstmal so ein bisschen bedeckt sein an
der Nordseeküste da könnte es auch mal
kurz tröpfeln dann wechseln Sonne und
Wolken miteinander ab nachmittags
entwickeln sich dann vor allen Dingen
über den Bergen einige Gewitter und mit
solchen Schauern und Gewittern haben wir
es dann am Mittwoch in einem Streifen
von der Nordseeküste bis zum Erzgebirge
zu tun und auch aus den Alpen heraus
kann es Schauer geben danach wird es
deutlich regnerischer und auch kühler
endlich guten Abend